Gary Vaynerchuk is a fast-talking
irreverent business guru who calls
himself a serial entrepreneur his twin
passions passions I share incidentally a
wine and social media his latest book is
for Thank You economy thank Gary joins
me now
what is the Thank You economy Gary you
know the the word economy was the big
part of this title I think what it is is
it's the tackling the issue of the ROI
of social media all these businesses
that you know I consult for they want to
know well what's the value of a million
fans on Facebook or what do I get if I
actually interact with people on Twitter
and and I'm also answer the answer is
everything's going old school appears
you know I think your grandparents are
more equipped to run business today than
we are because they actually cared about
their customer you know consumers don't
want to be talked to anymore they're
pounded with commercials and print and
newspaper ads and billboards and I think
now that we can listen to them they're
actually looking to shop with the people
that actually care about them so how do
you run your business you develop this
extraordinary Empire worth tens of
millions of dollars from basically a
liquor store and you've done it online
in a very aggressive and smart way
what's been the secret of why you
succeeded where so many others have I
think two things you know I was born in
Belarus I'm an immigrant so ridiculous
hard work is interesting to me right
it's in our DNA so what what I did in o7
when I started using Twitter was I
realized everybody was going to mess
this up everybody was going to look to
push more stuff watch my show tonight at
9:00 right buy my stuff do this
everybody was gonna push messages what I
did was I used a site called summize
which no longer exists twitter bought it
it's now search Twitter and my opinion
it's one of the most important sites in
the world I just searched Chardonnay and
Shiraz and Chateau Latour look what
people were saying and responded to it
creating contacts and relationship which
then allowed people to discover who I
was so you were seeking out customers
yeah I was seeking out real look you
know yes no question I'm not mother
Teresa I'm not this is the Thank You
economy I'm not Zen rock climbing
drinking tea and saying you know I'm
doing this for kicks and giggles I want
to build business I want to buy the New
York Jets right I just realized that
there's a different way to do it today
you know Eric Schmidt the former CEO of
Google the other day said you know more
content
is being produced in 48 hours than was
produced from the beginning of mankind
until 2003 consumers are inundated
pounded with messaging of course they're
tuning all that out and not listening to
the pitches that we've all done silly I
don't want to promote my show for
example yeah which I try and do on
Twitter as much as I can what is the
most effective way that I should be
doing it i watch your show a lot right
and in the corner here in the bottom
where everybody's looking right now it
says follow Pierce on Twitter yeah I
think it should say conversate or
interact with Pierce on Twitter right
for celebrities and people which shows
they play too much inside baseball you
know everybody's talking to each other
the celebrities are talking to each
other and that's not real to anybody
watching this to me what you should be
doing is you should be searching Peters
to your account right looking at what
people are saying and interact with the
actual listeners instead of pushing out
a tweet so forget all that kind of
egocentric you know narcissistic
nonsense between celebrities anybody
who's one but are you right there Ben
don't a lot of people come on Twitter
yep precisely so they can watch
celebrities feuding with each other no
question and there's plenty
entertainment value and nothing should
be all-in right you should have a mix
but in my opinion if you look at my
Twitter stream if you go to twitter.com
slash Gary Vee you will see a boatload
of at replies which is thank you Pinot
Grigio a wink a hug and then you'll say
hey buy my book listen I want to sell my
book but I think it needs to be one push
for every thousand or hundred polls so
it's a kind of modern version of
customer cares
absolutely and you'll get as you say
you're going back to what the the
grandparents used to do which is the guy
in the local liquor store for example
the butcher gave you know why is it a
baker's dozen they cared and more
importantly let's understand what really
is happening now we live on a
word-of-mouth foundation so when
somebody's watching your show if you go
and look up your name and say hey thanks
so much for watching my show because
they made a comment right you know when
they say oh my god Piers Morgan just
responded to me their entire social
graph is seeing that and 230 people that
is following that person sees that and
says wait a minute you know what Pierce
is a real dude maybe I'm going to check
out his show or when a Pepsi responds
instead of just doing a Super Bowl
commercial you know that means something
that Dane age is coming
I'll give you an analogy the pet dog now
with me Pearson oh this is a little
weird the pet dog in the 50s it was an
outdoor creature right by percentage by
data the dog was outside over the last
50 years not only has it come into the
home but it's in the bed and we're
dressing it and feeding it better than
we are ourselves I believe that we're
living through the humanization of
business this is the beginning but I
believe that you're not gonna do with
the fat dog well what that has to do
with the pet dog is that people are
treating a pet dog more like a human
that they did 50 years ago and I believe
you're gonna treat logos and brands the
same way you will have a conversation
with Nike or Reebok or Ford about
something that has nothing to do with
their core business in the future
because of this infrastructure and that
changes everything
what if you watch it is you haven't got
a clue about the incident where should
you start to start a business yeah but
you're pretty useless on the online yeah
what are the most simple effective ways
to make your business start to sing you
know obviously it's super different for
a small entrepreneur listening right now
compared to you know a fortune 500
company and and the book really tries to
tackle both entities I think for
somebody who's just starting a business
you've got to go to the googles and the
bings of the world and start searching
if you're not educated on how to use it
we live in a day and age where you can
go to youtube right now and watch a
video of how to use all this stuff but
the biggest problem and I got this all
the time with my last book which was
much more geared towards the
entrepreneur everybody just wants to
push their product they said Gary well I
don't have any followers well I didn't
either I didn't have a TV platform I
wasn't you know a world-known character
I went out and got the fans I fished for
them and that's what I think brands have
to do how expert are you in your field
of wine I'm pretty solid as you know we
were just talking right before the
greatest wine of all time when I said 47
Shabalin hero hug the 47 should right no
and I said the second one was that what
you thought was first 51 the top right
so and we were talking we're talking
about 29 s and 45s I think that's super
important I'm glad you brought that up
the biggest problem that I see in social
media today and there's so many social
media experts they've never really built
a business you know I built a 60 million
dollar business before I started talking
about how to use social to build a
business you have to know your craft
because no matter how good at marketing
you are and no matter how good you are
at fishing social media if you don't
know what you're talking about
you've lost then content is always King
if I want to buy wine off you how do I
know that you're gonna get me the best
example of that wine well I mean I think
there's a variety of different things I
mean obviously you know for us with
winelibrary.com my family business with
my dad
Sasha we were very price driven my dad's
liquor store was called shoppers
discount liquors you know growing up you
know there's reputation there's Yelp
reviews there's people conversating
right now on Facebook and Twitter
there's new sites like tumblr right and
Cora and Instagram that are changing
landscape and getting information from
the social web is how you're going to
figure that out if we're legit or not
see here's the biggest thing that I see
going on piers why I called it the Thank
You economy billions of dollars going to
be impacted by the maturity of the web
see Twitter and Facebook are getting all
the credit but what's really happening
here
is the internet is maturing it's only 17
years old the internet that we all know
the consumer web the one that a o L sent
the discs in the mail to get us to sign
up for is only 17 years old
we are grossly as a culture under
estimating the impact of this social web
we have a quick break when we come back
I want to ask you whether the problem
with the Internet is as we get more
obsessed with it we've become a bunch of
boring geeks yeah
like now my guest Gary Vaynerchuk Gary
it's a fascinating thing the internet
and it's obsessing all of us but it's
the danger that we all just become a
bunch of boring dead-eyed geeks it's
been 20 hours a day on our computers you
know I think people dramatically become
more social see I'm very countercultural
everybody's talking about like our kids
are not social anymore I don't see it
I've been able to have dramatically more
relationships because of the internet
and it was real ones oh just online
dramatically real ones see I don't have
a difference between online and real for
example when I go to South by Southwest
a big tech conference and a lot of
people that in that place I'm like you
I'm a little thing right and I get a lot
of people coming to me it's amazing to
me through one or two engagements that I
have context with the person that's
coming to me right I don't you know I
don't know them like my best friend but
we're starting at a different point
because of our interaction online and I
think they bleed together that's my big
point with the Superbowl commercials by
the way this year I thought they sucked
Peters I couldn't believe in 2011 that
nobody ran a commercial that extended it
to the web right I mean how do you leave
all those conversations on the table
they need to work together and so I view
it as another platform to create context
of relationships and keep them these
relationships I mean people compete over
followers on Twitter or friends I agree
with Facebook and stuff it's all a bit
shallow isn't it it's ridiculous it's an
arms race
it's a keeping up with the Joneses and
people gonna wake up in a year or two
and realize well what does that really
mean right and you see it with brands
with their big competitors they want to
fight you see with celebrities wanting
to outdo each other know myself I
believe that it's not about the numbers
and it's not about the pushing out the
content it's simply about the engagement
and in my opinion what social has done
its scaling caring I'm telling you that
if you took a different tack if Ford
took a different tack that they actually
listened and replied the context that
that creates is different similar to the
butcher
you know why the small town rules worked
because they knew your kids were going
to graduate in a month they knew that
your husband just got promoted it was
small town the internet even though it's
big all these gadgets and widgets
they're bringing the world closer to
each other we know
or about each other and that's an
important contact shift when he saw
President Obama have his big powwow with
all the internet geniuses recently if
you've been at that table what would you
have been telling him well probably a
lot of different things but you know I
mean I would have said this listen the
president has a lot of restrictions that
don't allow him or the White House to
use it the way we kind of want him to
but I think anything that humanizes
anything is interesting humanizes a
business I think what Obama can do and
he has to obviously look at the rules
that he's living within is humanized the
office right I mean again the
president's always in the push business
he gives a talk to the monitor and he
pushes any kind of interaction that is
allowed and I don't know all the rules
of what he's allowed to do I think would
be enormous and that's where I would
tell him to go how do you regulate the
internet how do you stop I've got three
young sons and you stop them being
bombarded with nasty stuff sure so I
talk about this a lot you know there was
there was a site called formspring that
came out a couple about a year ago that
caused a lot of hoopla anonymous QA and
it got a little nasty I talked to a lot
of parents when I'm on the radio and
different things here's what I think
about it first of all and this is a big
statement and I mean this with all my
heart
we humans are grossly underestimated and
grossly underrated with all the access
that we have the amount of bad things
that happen is shockingly low I mean we
have to paint that picture first and
foremost to understand but you've got to
be a good parent I mean there's
software's that can track things no
question if you don't have access to
your laptop of your underage kid you're
making a mistake you've got to be a good
parent
now it's hard I mean I don't want to
paint a picture that it's easy but I
think the top line thesis is for every
story about the girl that used Facebook
and found a bad guy there's billions of
interactions that are not creating any
negative aspects when you see all the
revolutionary uprising yes across the
Middle East and the social networking
aspect of that has been extraordinary to
observe yeah with them getting round
these repressive regimes by just talking
to each other yeah you must be excited
by that of course I mean again thank you
economy is really a business-oriented
book when I walk into a CEO of fortune
100 company I say if you think that this
is not in
acting your business but it's up rising
countries you've got it completely
twisted I mean this is the biggest
platform that has ever hit the human
race we are grossly under estimating it
and of course Egypt's happening and it's
going to continue listen with WikiLeaks
that affected the u.s. everybody has to
understand and they don't want to pierce
nobody wants to accept what's really
happening here which is that the game
has changed and the rules of that game
are very difficult for people that want
to control I am excited about it I am
here's my problem
yeah you know I don't go shopping
anymore I buy everything online okay my
three sons 17 13 and 10 yep
spend hours and hours a day yep yep
can't be good for anybody that we just
don't get out as much it's better than
them watching TV let's not paint a
picture of what was happening behind is
this better than going up playing
Spalding yes but that view but that
wasn't happening in the 80s or 90s
either they were watching television and
playing video games we were a long ways
away from little Ricky going out and
playing ball I mean you know it's not
like this is a new phenomenon and more
importantly they're a lot more worldly
our kids right you must look at your
sons and be shot I think they're smarter
than I was at the same and it's not even
closer the better informed they get news
better faster but their attention span I
is absolutely miniscule no question but
I have a family friend little Lou right
he used a site called chat roulette do
you remember that thing I got a lot of
attention too he found a family in like
Peru
he spent the hour and a half talking to
them you know who they were his context
of his life how good he has it changed
forever
no documentary in class no sitting down
with your son telling him you got it so
good
none of that could have done it so
there's enormous positive coming out of
these innovations you just got to look
for it these big companies you don't
advise are you shocked by how
non-internet savvy they are you know at
first I was going to be the punk kid
entrepreneur and you're gonna do it this
way and you guys all don't get it I've
learned over the last couple years of
working with lottie's companies they get
it they're just playing a different rule
the Thank You economy the new social web
is about running a marathon Perce it's
about creating a real relationship it's
about marrying somebody instead of
having a one-night stand
the
problem for all these big businesses is
they report quarterly right they're
playing a different game the street is
looking at their numbers and they have a
very difficult time going all-in on
investing in something that takes a long
time to develop so what I'm trying to do
is help them form little ninja units
while they're doing what they're
supposed to do and how much how much do
they pay you for this privilege well
they pay lots of money right vaynermedia
charges you know between twenty and
thirty thousand dollars a month for
consulting and community management so
it's not I'm not revolutionising the
world but it's a solid living well given
I've got you here for nothing yeah
obviously as we took the opportunity so
forget Twitter for a moment how else
would you promote my show what is what's
the smartest coolest way let me
recommend an audience first and foremost
top-line thesis it's not about you
talking out it's not about you talking
SLB hey Stan I understand it's about
listening I'll tell you what I would do
first and foremost the only way that I
would use Twitter is through search
Twitter looking up your name and the
shows names the guest you have on and
actually engaging with people not named
Ryan Seacrest or Kim Kardashian actual
human beings right number two I think
tumblr is the most important site of
2011 it is exploding it's a micro
blogging platform I think you would push
out content there maybe behind the
scenes clip maybe after we're done
taping this we do a little flip cam
thing and you push it out there a
different place to do something we
actually do that on our site yeah CNN I
think that's great and I think Cora have
you looked at Corey yet yeah so Cora is
a Q&A platform has a very dark horse
chance of becoming the new Wikipedia you
know it's gonna be interesting to see
where they go I would go in there as you
you're pretty knowledgeable smart dude
I'd go in there find things that you
know answers to and answer them Pierce
you're a major star Thank You Garrett
okay thank you is it again you have to
humanize yourself and so does Pepsi and
so does Ford and so does the National
Hockey League the consumer was saying
really we're seeing the whole world
everybody now believes they have a voice
don't they that's what I find very
interesting because they you know you
get the reaction on Twitter and half
them saying great things about you half
want to kill you sure but I quite like
the freedom that this Twitter and social
network has brought people to have an
opinion absolutely better to have an
opinion
no opinion right and the marketers that
are sitting in the room or the people
that are you know marketing the show no
longer can you be like it's working you
get instant feedback right you know and
I think it's just level the playing
field it here's what it is peers it's a
different skill set for a long time the
person that could give the best
PowerPoint presentation one now it's the
person who has the best skills in a
cocktail party and every business and
celebrity that has better skills in
cocktail party instead of presentation
is going to win going who is your
biggest rival and I really you know is
the one you look to the thing that
they're stepping up yeah the one person
that I would set you know that's a great
question you can see stumped me and I
can answer everything I don't really
think of it that way I don't want to
give the real answer is good arrive you
know I don't want to give the real
answer which is that I think I'm better
than everybody that's fair enough
you know but who do you see threatening
your hat I'm always scary other Gary I'm
scared of anybody who's bigger than I am
who will work as hard as I will you know
Fallon's scared me when he first came
out cuz I thought he was gonna really
interact Andy Cohen at Bravo I think is
a sneaky kind of character right Kim
Kardashian is probably executing it as
well as anybody cuz six million photos I
had her on here yeah I got a look at the
camera and say follow piers moon are
literally sure it exploded I mean I got
about thirty thousand followers you know
what ventilation vaynernation follow
Piers Morgan I wanna I wanna Trump a Kim
the vaso view cooler the vane and a
maniacs a baby act you know appears I
think that anybody who's got a bigger
platform than me who's willing to bleed
out of their eyeballs for their
community will beat me
anybody who's smaller won't because I'm
just gonna outwork everybody Gary good
luck thank you my friend good to meet
you real pleasure that was Gary
Vaynerchuk